Okay rogan
experience
paradise.
Why are you right now?
And uh,
I was gonna I was gonna Watch the Bisping fight the Bisbing Kelvin guests limb
fight live and uh,
do like sort of a breakdown of it while it was happening.
But the shit was going on at like two o'clock in the morning out here and
it wasn't happening.
I have been eating like a pig and drinking.
I've been doing vacation type shit.
I'm a strong believer in that you need to do vacation time.
Like vacation time is important.
You can't just be working all the time.
Occasionally you have to just fuck off.
And so that's what I've been doing.
I just been fucking off.
So I,
I was tired and I decided I am not going to stay up late.
And so I watched it in the morning.
I watched it this morning and I've got a couple of thoughts on it.
First of all,
um,
Brennan Chub said this on his Instagram and I could not agree more.
I don't think you should be allowed to fight three weeks after you have a brutal
fight like Michael Bisping did with GSP.
He got rocked,
he got choked unconscious and then three weeks later he's fighting a really
dangerous,
yeah,
young and up and coming Kelvin gas alum and Calvin is a beast.
He's gotten nasty boxing and that is what he showed in that fight.
He hit him with a beautiful straight right jab and a right hand behind it and oh
my goodness.
It was just,
that kid is just on fire.
He's,
he's just on another level right now.
I'm super,
super impressed with Calvin.
Calvin has got lightening fast hands and he's,
he's an interesting guy because he's what I would call a tweener.
And what that means is that I don't,
I mean I think Kelvin
in
in the best,
best of times,
like if Calvin has the best camp and the the best performance,
it's entirely possible that he could beat anybody at 185 pounds.
But should he be at 185 pounds?
Boy,
I don't know because Chris Weidman is that 185 pounds.
And when Chris Weidman got Calvin to the ground,
it really did look like you're talking about two completely different weight
classes.
And Chris Weidman was able to show Calvin out.
And obviously Weidman is a former champion and there's absolutely no shame in
losing to Chris Weidman,
but it's just the way
it looked when you were watching the fight.
To me it looked like two different weight classes.
And,
um,
there's a lot of people that think that really Calvin should be fighting at 170
pounds if he got the proper diet.
And he was doing that for a while.
Uh,
it was at one point in time,
he was,
uh,
no,
dolce was working with them for a while and,
uh,
he had his diet in line and he looked fantastic and then,
you know,
just things happen and he didn't want to pay the dolce money.
And,
uh,
I dunno who he's working with right now as a nutritionist,
but I just,
uh,
I think he's a phenomenal fighter.
I just don't know if 185 pounds is,
is the right way class form.
It could be.
I mean,
it could be that maybe what he really needs to do is just lose some body fat,
put on some muscle and maybe 185 pounds will be his weight class.
It's just that constant debate of whether or not you should weaken your body and
dropped down to the minimum weight you can or whether or not you should fight at
a natural way and have a healthy body.
It's,
it's a real good argument.
And I'm pausing right now because I'm pulling something up.
Uh,
there's a girl that just died in Australia.
she died
very recently.
Uh,
she was preparing for a Moitai fight and it's just,
it's just part of what this sport is about.
Unfortunately.
It did really bothers the fucking shit out of me.
I think it's the scariest thing.
Uh,
I think,
um,
yeah.
Here it is.
Teenager dies training.
Um,
the,
the girl's name,
she was 18 years old and uh,
her name was Jessica Lindsey and she died while she was cutting weight.
She was an amateur kickboxer and Australia.
Um,
I cut weight a bunch of times when I was doing taekwondo tournaments and,
uh,
it is brutal.
It's,
it's terrible.
I was bad at it too.
I didn't do it correctly.
I just worked out real hard the night before and more rubber suits and the whole
deal and dehydrated myself and I didn't rehydrate myself well either.
So I felt like shit the next day when I was fighting.
And,
uh,
a lot of wrestlers back in the day used to do the same thing.
Um,
my weight cut though was nowhere near as extreme as some of the MMA fighters do.
Some MMA fighters.
I mean,
they're getting on death's door and,
um,
I just,
I just think it's a,
one of the most disturbing and a most unfortunate aspects of MMA.
Uh,
Kevin Lee said before his last fight with Tony Ferguson that,
you know,
he felt like he was,
he was dying when he was cutting weight and he made the weight Habib number go
Madoff,
who is the,
if not the best,
one of the very best lightweights in the world.
Um,
undefeated
had his body shut down last time.
He tried to make the weight and couldn't make the Tony Ferguson fight.
They pulled him out and took him to the hospital.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm beating a dead horse here cause it's something that everybody knows.
Everybody's aware that it's a terrible,
terrible aspect of our sport.
And in my mind it's contrary to what martial arts is supposed to be about.
So in that sense,
I encourage Kelvin to stay at 185 pounds because obviously the guy's knocked out
Vidor Belford at one 85 he just knocked out a former champion,
Michael Bisbing at 185 pounds.
I mean,
he could knock on anybody at one 85 but a guy like Chris Weidman who is very
smart about cutting weight,
he cuts a lot of weight,
but he does it the right way.
Rehydrates the right way and he's just a fucking beast.
He's just so much bigger.
And when he got Kelvin to the ground and submitted him with a head and arm choke
boy,
it just really seemed like that's the wrong way class for Calvin.
And then you see Calvin next fight,
fight Bisbing and just fucking lights him up in the first round.
Now would he have been able to do that if he fought the Bisbing that was
training for George Saint Pierre.
I mean,
if Bisping did not have the George Saint Pierre fight and it just went right
into the Calvin Gasland fight with the same result of happen,
it could very well have the way Calvin hits,
he's fast as fuck.
His hands are beautiful.
He throws really crisp straight punches.
And in this sport it's,
there's not a whole lot of guys who have crisper,
sharper hands at 185 pounds.
Then Calvin,
I mean,
he just has beautiful head movement and boxing and when he moves in for the kill
with those hands,
whoa.
When you saw the Vito Belfort fight,
I mean he just fucking be tore up,
but those straight punches and he throws them efficiently and they have snapped
to them.
And just,
and on top of that,
he's a very good wrestler.
I mean,
a lot of people forget how good his wrestling skills are on top of all that.
He's just a real threat at 185 pounds.
Fascinating thing because it's just such a wide open division.
He just called out,
um,
Robert Whitaker,
who was the interim champion of course,
and a call that Whittaker and wants Whitaker to,
uh,
to fight him next.
But of course,
Robert Whitaker is a waiting for the big pay day.
I would too if I was him to fight George St Pierre.
So it's a,
it's a wide open division now that Saint Pierre choked out.
Michael Bisbing and then Gelt Kelvin just lights up.
Bisping.
And of course,
you've got to think that Weidman is still in the mix.
I mean,
even though why been lost to Yoel Romero.
And then last two gig garden was saucy.
He's still in the mix.
Uh,
he was winning that Yoel Romero fight,
in my opinion until he got caught,
was that wicked flying knee.
But that's the danger of fighting Gol Romero,
you all Romero could do that to anybody in the world.
He's just such a fucking freak athlete.
Uh,
so really,
really wide open division.
I'm bombed as fuck that gay guard went over.
And,
uh,
decided to,
fight for bell tour,
but I get it,
you know,
I mean these guys got to go where the money is and at Pella tour he easily could
be a champion.
I think he could be a champion in the UFC as well.
And maybe we will see him in the UFC again.
I mean,
he could easily find a year or two over in the UFC and then come back over.
K guard is still relatively young,
but it's nice to have competition.
I think competition is good for everybody and I think it,
uh,
I think it really elevates the sport.
It elevates the level of sport.
I end it,
you could see by the results that a lot of these UFC fighters are having.
Um,
especially Lorens Larkin who is very good,
he's a very,
very good striker.
He loses to Lima in a bid for the title and then loses by,
knock out to the always dangerous pol daily.
So I think Bella tore it.
And now,
especially in that 170 pound division,
you've got Rory McDonald bell tours really showing they have absolute world
championship caliber,
caliber talent over there.
So to get back to that fight,
uh,
I agree entirely with a,
to get back to the Bisbing and,
uh,
Calvin Gasol and fight,
I agree 100% with what Brendan Schaub said,
that you really have to protect a fighter from themselves.
You really can't be letting a guy fight three weeks after an absolutely brutal
fight like that.
It just does not make sense.
Um,
I don't think it's smart.
I mean,
I understand that UFC needed someone to fill in and short notice because
Anderson Silva tested positive for performance enhancing drugs and they did not
want to lose the,
uh,
Shanghai main event.
So it turns into an even bigger fight when you've got the former middleweight
champion right off of his last three weeks later fighting again.
But
it's just not smart.
I know Bisping wanted to do it.
I know Bisping would probably do it again if you asked to do,
if you,
if you ask Bisbing to fight in a couple of weeks of probably,
probably do it again.
And,
and,
um,
someone was talking about him fighting in England,
I believe in March,
which
boy,
I mean,
that's less crazy,
but still crazy,
right?
Because,
uh,
we're basically an into December.
So you got December,
January,
February,
three months off really,
and then march.
But of course during that time he's going to be sparring and you know,
you know,
Bisping,
he's a fucking animal.
He's not going to train easy.
He's not gonna take much time off.
And,
uh,
there's a lot of debate as to how much time a fighter should be forced to take
off after they get knocked out.
And here's the thing about that.
You're,
you're seeing guys
when they're fighting and you're seeing them getting knocked down and you're
seeing them fighting,
you know,
x amount of months later.
So you saw Bisping,
he didn't get knocked out by George Saint Pierre,
but he's certainly got rocked with that left hook.
And then,
uh,
he got choked out when he was on the ground.
I now,
for people who don't know a lot about MMA,
getting choked out is not nearly as bad as getting knocked out.
It's,
there's almost nothing to it.
The way to look at it is if you look at a garden hose and you know how to give
Ben the garden hose,
crimp it down and it stops the water from coming out.
That's exactly what happens to your fucking brain when you get choked out.
When you get choked out,
it's basically cutting off the blood.
Your brain,
you wake up and you're fine.
You don't have memory issues,
you don't have balance issues for the most part,
especially if you've only been out for a couple of seconds.
Um,
it happens all of the time in training.
Uh,
I've seen many,
many guys get choked unconscious.
I've choked people unconscious.
They come back and they're fine.
It's not that big of a deal,
but you got to realize before he got choked unconscious,
he got hit with a big fucking lefthand and hurt.
And it was a great fight before that.
Uh,
both guys were were giving and tanking fighters need time off after fights.
So you're seeing that,
right?
You're seeing the actual competition between George Saint Pierre,
Michael Bisping.
What were you not seeing is how many times he got hit during training?
Did he get rocked ever?
Did he get clipped and dropped a,
did he get dropped and heard and take a couple of days off and then get back to
training again?
Only he knows.
Only his camp knows and most of the times they're not talking.
But you hear about it all the time.
And matter of fact,
I was talking to Forrest Griffin wants,
and Forrest was telling me that before he fought Anderson Silva,
he was knocked unconscious twice in training.
That's fucking crazy.
I mean,
here he is
about to fight the greatest pound for pound fighter of all time.
Next to,
I mean if there's,
there's,
there's three guys in that debate,
right?
My,
my number one guy right now is mighty mouse.
I think just he,
he represents the highest skill level.
But does he represent the highest competition level in terms of like the guys
he's faced?
I don't think so.
I think number one competition level is Jon Jones.
Jon Jones has choked out Liotta Machida rampage Jackson.
He's beat Rashad Evans.
He beat Alexander Gustafson,
he'd beat Glover to sharer.
He beat Vitor Belfort.
He beat Daniel Cormier twice.
I mean fuck,
he's beating everybody.
I think you look at competition wise,
Jon Jones is a very strong argument for the greatest of all time,
but Anderson Silva's fucking bright there too,
man.
Anderson Silva in his prime.
I think when you look at the way he knocked out,
Vitor Belfort with that front kick to the face,
when you look at the way he fought,
Forrest Griffin in,
in that fight that we were just talking about,
and k owed him like a magician the way he fought Stephan Bonner and literally
put his back up against the cage.
They again,
Stephan Bonner and Forrest Griffin to just,
no disrespect,
they're not at the same level as a Leo Machida or Glover to sharer or some of
the guys that Jon Jones has faced,
but it's the way Anderson beat them.
I mean,
Anderson was just in his prime.
He was off fucking master,
like a real master.
Uh,
so Forrest Griffin fighting Anderson Silva after being Kao twice in training
camp is just insane.
But these are the things that fighters do when they have to do them.
You know,
you're talking about a giant pay day,
you're talking about a big fight.
You give the guy a chance like,
do you want to fight?
Do you think you could fight?
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
I could do it.
And they go out there and they're compromised and they get clipped and you see
it immediately.
Sometimes.
Sometimes you see guys,
they get clipped and you don't know what I mean.
They get hit with something and look at any day,
any time when a person is throwing a punch or kick at you and it connects,
it can put you out.
But there's no doubt at all,
no doubt about it,
that the resiliency of a fighter after they'd been KOD is compromised.
There's just no doubt about it.
When you see a guy who's been KOD and then you see them get hit weeks,
months later,
they cannot take a shot at the same way.
Their brain is still recovering,
their body is still recovering from the concussion.
And uh,
you have to figure out a way to balance being a risk taker and seizing an
opportunity,
which is a huge opportunity versus concentrating on having a long and healthy
career.
Now that said,
for Michael Bisping,
he's kind of at the end of his career.
I mean,
he said essentially that he wants to fight one more time in England,
which would be beautiful for him and I hope they give him,
uh,
you know,
a good matchup.
So it'd be a good fight for the fans.
And I hope they give Michael some time off.
You know,
give the man some time to really relax and then go through a real nice three,
four month training camp,
get an excellent shape and give his best effort for one more.
Go at it.
I would like to see that,
but it might be the hardest shit in the world to talk a fighter into retiring or
to for a fighter to figure out when to retire.
I was just talking to Matt Brown.
Um,
he came to see me in Denver and I was telling him,
I was like,
dude,
that fight that you have with Diego Sanchez,
what a perfect way to go out.
Beautiful,
spectacular knockouts,
Classic Matt Brown fight.
Just blood and guts.
He's one of my all time favorite fighters to watch for sure because he's so
fucking for Roche's.
You knew when you were going to go to see a matte brown fight.
If Matt Brown was fighting,
anybody win,
lose or draw,
that guy was going to have to face hell.
Matt Brown would bring it in.
The four Rosti intensity that that guy would bring inside the octagon is just
unrivaled.
And I think about Matt is,
he's,
he's not like an unbelievably physically gifted guy.
He's not like some Kevin Randleman character.
You know,
there's been guys that are just physical freaks.
Anthony Rumble Johnson,
there's a,
you know Brock Lesnar,
there's,
there's guys that are just physically,
they're just freakish.
They can do things that are just incredibly unusual.
And then there's guys that their mind is just unbreakable.
They're just off fucking warrior to the core down to the cells.
That's Matt Brown and Matt Brown can lose.
He's lost before,
but he just loses because his body gives out.
It's never because his mind gives out.
I mean that guy is coming to fucking kill you every time he gets into that
octagon.
And I loved that about him.
I mean it's one of my all time favorite fighters to watch for sure.
And when I was telling him a congratulations,
I mean it's an amazing way to cap off a career.
He's like,
might not be the last one.
So he's still,
you know,
even after going through all those wars,
he's in his thirties now,
I believe he's like 35 I think he is maybe 36 and you know,
still wondering.
I think he's 36 it's still wondering like is this it to go one more do one more,
one more.
Cause the thrill that you experience.
I mean obviously I've never fought inside the octagon so I'm just guessing.
But the thrill of just fighting in general,
it's such a much higher level of danger and excitement than most people
experience in everyday life and it's incredibly addictive and it makes regular
life seem dull and gray in comparison.
When those guys get into the octagon,
when a guy like Matt Brown smashes an elbow down on Diego Sanchez and Diego
slumps and goes limp and the crowd goes insane.
And you know when just when Matt got into the octagon,
there's a crazy video of the fight while we're watching the fight,
Matt steps into the octagon steps through the cage and fucking roars.
I mean raw bars,
like you see it in his face,
you see it in his eyes.
He just opens his mouth and screams that mother fucker was there to fight.
That's what he loves to do.
And it was finally there.
It was finally happening.
It gets to the training camp steps into that octagon.
It's go time.
That is is exciting as life is going to be for him or for,
for any combat sports athlete.
And it is incredibly,
incredibly hard to give that up.
Once you've experienced that man,
I mean,
you see it in these guys.
It's so hard for them to know when to walk away,
but I think it's incredibly critical to balance out the glory of Combat Sports,
the glory of giving your all and going out on your shield sometimes and
sometimes winning with vicious knockout or incredible submission,
but knowing when the body has taken enough,
knowing when your vehicle is damaged to the point where you should not be
engaging in competition anymore.
And it's different for everybody and it's so hard to figure out when,
and some guys just know,
some guys just know and they'll go,
you know what?
I'm good.
It's it,
uh,
I don't feel it anymore.
I'm going to step away.
Um,
Tj grants a good example of that.
Here's a guy that was supposed to be fighting for the title.
He's about to fight for the UFC lightweight title and nobody ever heard from him
again.
He was suffering from concussion syndrome.
He just had real hard time recovering from a concussion that he gotten training
and uh,
never fought again.
Took a regular job,
but he's done some training,
training fighters and stuff,
but never decided to get back into the octagon again.
Chris Holdsworth and other example got a training injury,
get hit in the head and training real bad,
got a concussion and um,
decided to stop.
And that was it.
Very hard for these guys to figure out when.
So,
um,
next Saturday,
December 2nd,
there's a big fight.
It's the rematch between Max Holloway and Josie Aldo.
You also have Alistair Overeem and Francis in Ghana on that card.
Whoa.
Henry said Udo and Sergio Pettis,
Eddie Alvarez,
and just engaging who?
Just those four fights,
right?
Their whole Lee Shit.
Holy Shit.
I know a,
I talked about Holloway versus all though before.
Um,
what I like about this fight is first of all,
the first fight was very good until,
although,
um,
ran out of gas and Holloway took over.
Um,
all those camp was saying that going into that fight all though had a leg
injury,
which kind of makes sense because you really didn't throw many leg kicks,
but he also didn't throw very many leg kicks against Frankie Edgar.
I think the strategy for then for that fight though was that he was worried
about the takedowns of Frankie Edgar.
So he had decided to avoid being taken down.
One of the best ways to do it would be just to avoid kicking and just outbox
him.
And he did that very well in that fight and won a pretty clear unanimous
decision.
This is going to be a different fighter.
I mean Max Holloway is in his prime.
He beat,
although the first time around isn't he?
And he's incredibly confident there's going to be able to beat all the second
time.
All go though said that he had this leg injury and it prevented him from
throwing leg kicks but that it's better now.
And that's one of the reasons why he's excited about fighting Holloway again.
Now if that is the case and if all though is in tremendous shape,
cause he took this fight on relatively short notice,
he did not get a full two,
three month training camp.
I think it was five weeks out,
maybe more.
I'm sorry if I'm wrong about that.
I'm not looking at it right in front of me but I know it wasn't a full camp
cause I know it was supposed to be Frankie Edgar Edgar got injured and so all
those steps in,
so we're gonna find out,
we're going to find out if Aldo can make the proper adjustments and whether or
not the ability to throw leg kicks is going to make a difference because all
those leg kicks classically in history have been some of the very best in the
game.
If you look at his fight with Uriah Faber,
it's one of the very best uses,
uses best use of leg kicks maybe in the featherweight division ever.
And just smash Uriah Faber,
his leg to the point where,
I mean it's one of the all time grossest and injuries and MMA you rise left leg
was like twice the size of his right leg and had to do a bunch of crazy therapy
to recover from him hyperbaric chamber.
And you know,
he documented it.
Your eyes.
He's such a cool dude.
He's uh,
I loved that he did this.
He,
he documented a lot of the injury online to show everybody like,
look how fucked up my leg is.
And uh,
that's all done at its best is although the same guy now,
I mean he's gone through 29 professional MMA fights at the highest level.
He's been a champion for a long time and you know,
he's had some wars.
The second fight with Chad Mendez was a war.
Of course he got stopped quick by Conor Mcgregor.
The fight with Max Holloway was a war.
I mean,
he's been through some,
some really tough fights.
Does he still have that same level?
You know,
we really don't know.
And we're going to find out,
hopefully we're going to find out from a an inch.
I mean,
I don't know what kind of camp he was involved in,
like how hard he was training rather before he entered into camp for this
championship fight.
I'm hoping that he was in good shape and that's one of the reasons why he was so
eager to take the fight.
And we're gonna find out we're going to fly out on Saturday night.
And that's very interesting.
But maybe even more interesting is Alistair Overeem and Francis in Ghana,
because Alistair are over.
Overeem was one of the most experienced guys in the division.
Of course,
Overeem is the former dream heavyweight champion,
former Strikeforce heavyweight champion and former k one grand Prix champion.
One of the very best kick boxers to ever fight in MMA without a doubt.
But you want to talk about a guy who has been in wars like let's Google Allister
overall record because it's gotta be fucking crazy.
As far as the number of times he's been stopped.
I mean,
it's really fucking bananas.
Let's go and look.
We'll first look at his MMA career.
We'll count this up and this is no disrespect to him.
I'm a huge Alistair Overeem fan and I'm not saying that he should retire or
anything crazy like that,
but let's just take a look at how many times he's been stopped.
Just an MMA.
Okay.
So he won two fights in a row,
a fantastic victory over Mark Hunt.
It Kod him with knees and one a split decision over for breezy over doom.
Um,
or actually a majority decision.
One,
one of the referees,
I guess call or one of the judges called it a draw.
I thought that was a very close decision,
but I thought that [inaudible] was going to get the nod.
Quite honestly.
Let's look at the,
the times he's lost though.
Steep.
Amy.
Oh,
chip.
When he fought for the title,
knocked him out.
Okay.
Before that,
Ben Rothwell knocked him out before that Travis Browne knocked him out before
that Antonio big foot Silva knocked him out.
Brutal knockout.
So that's just within the last four years in the UFC.
He suffered for brutal knockouts before that surrogate Keratan off,
knocked him out.
Brutal knockout in 2007,
10 years ago,
Mauricio Shogun Hua knocked them out.
Also in 2007,
uh,
he lost to Ricardo Arona.
He got stopped in that fight.
He tapped two strikes,
a Ho Geria Nogueira uh,
stopped him.
Little Nog stopped him.
Uh,
his corner stopped it by,
it's a Tko.
That was in 2006.
He got stopped by Fabrizio over doom,
but that was a Komora and that was a submission.
Um,
Shogun who,
uh,
stopped him,
the first time in 2005 so shogun knocked him out twice.
He TKO them in 2005 and Kayo them in 2007 before that little Nog beat him by
decision chocolate dealt k owed him and a fantastic fight where overin was
really coming on strong against chuck.
And then,
uh,
chuck caught him with some brutal punches and killed him.
That was in 2003 before that,
Bobby Hoffman,
a lot of people forgot about Bobby Hoffman way back and rings.
Um,
Kay owed him in 2000 and that's it for MMA.
So just MMA chaos,
right?
The first Kale loss.
We have Bobby Hoffman than we have chocolate,
Dell.
Then we have shogun,
then we have a little Nog,
then we have a Rona,
then we have shogun again.
Then we have Keratan off.
Okay.
We already have seven that's Keratan off.
Then we have big foot Silva,
eight Travis Browne,
nine Ben Rothwell,
10 steep Emile Chick,
1111 stoppage losses in MMA.
I mean,
holy fucking shit.
That's crazy.
11 knockout or stoppage losses in MMA.
Then you'd go to kickboxing.
Badr.
Hari stopped him in the k one Grand Prix final in 2009.
He stopped him.
Um,
he got stopped by Glob a Tosa in,
um,
kill Kachin versus k one 2004,
he got Kod.
He got stopped by Bernard Paris and k one Holland.
That's in 2001,
so one,
two,
three k o losses and kickboxing on top of all the other MMA losses.
So that's a lot of fucking stoppage losses folks.
And it's led people to question the durability of the current guy.
But what we do know is that Allister is extremely crafty and one of the things
that I like about Allister these days as since he's gone over to Jackson
Winkeljohn in Albuquerque,
he has become much more elusive,
um,
much slicker on his feet,
moves around a lot more and doesn't just try to smash people.
The Uber Ream,
the guy that we saw fight Brock Lesnar when the,
in his UFC debut that was like classic Uber,
which is Jack to the tits smash and people running through people he would meet
force with greater force.
Now what you're seeing is we're seeing as the ouster over him the fuck junior
dos Santos who farted,
incredibly clever fight,
moved around.
Well,
um,
he was very,
very slick,
very difficult to hit and then started scoring on junior and then eventually
caught him with a beautiful left hook and Kale at him.
That's that to me is the interesting Andre Arlovski as tea today.
A guy who realizes that perhaps you can't take a punch like you did when he was
younger.
You know,
he's been in a lot of really,
really tough fights as we just went over and realized,
it's like,
hey,
now I have to be smart.
Now I have to be clever.
I have to move around a lot and I have to use my skills.
And his skills are substantial.
In my opinion.
He's the best,
I mean,
right up there with mark on of course,
um,
who he just beat the best heavyweight kickboxer every money it comes to
credentials.
He's the best.
Kevin heavyweight kickboxer ever in MMA.
Really a no,
no heavyweight kickboxer other than him and hunt have everyone,
the k one Grand Prix and hunt one it,
he stepped into the finals as an alternate.
He had lost earlier that night.
Uh,
not to take anything away from hunt because of course,
Mark Honda is still just one of the all time greats when it comes to kickboxing.
But when Mark Hunt One,
um,
he one,
we can go to that record right here,
Mark Hunt One,
um,
the k one grand Prix he wanted,
he had lost that night.
Um,
see,
he's,
he's fought the Caitlin Grand Prix a couple of times.
He lost a semi shelt uh,
he got a Tki owed by a spinning back kick and he won.
Um,
why don't I say God damn,
he's fought a lot of fucking awesome kickboxing fights too.
So he lost to race CFO in 2001 and the semifinals.
And then he won that night.
He beat Stefan Leco.
Yeah.
So he lost to Ray Sefo.
Ray Sefo apparently couldn't continue and then he came back to win from getting
that right.
Yeah.
It looks like he beat Stefan Leco
in the,
uh,
75 watts has semifinals says winds,
k one Grand Prix championship 2001.
Oh,
okay.
He fought Francisco Filio but that was in,
I'm looking at a different date.
That was in,
uh,
2002 or 2001 he'd be feeling,
anyway,
I'm rambling.
Did you notice?
Yeah,
I'm talking too much.
Um,
but,
so he's fighting Frances,
Frances and Ghana and Francis and Ghana who is right now 10 and one of the UFC
10,
uh,
ten one with a zero draws.
So 10 wins and it's just been smashing everybody.
And if he looked at his last fight against Andre Arlovski,
that was a fight where it's like probably one of the first fights where we
really got tested.
We really got to see what happens when he fights a former champion,
a former really world class fighter and a,
it was a good test,
but now a bigger test is in front of them when he's going to fight.
Alistair Overeem,
I mean we've seen him so far,
four times inside the octagon.
Uh,
he stopped Curtis blades by knockout.
He stopped bull hon.
I don't know how to say this guy's name again.
Me.
I owe Vich me how you've,
I don't remember how to get bullion.
Mihailo Vich I do remember how to say homeboy's name.
Um,
then he stopped Anthony Hamilton,
uh,
by submission showing that he has submission skills as well.
And then of course just knocked out Andre Arlovski in his last fight.
It's a very interesting fight because the,
the question is,
is in Ghana ready for a guy who's got the skills of Alistair over him?
The skill,
the experience at the highest level,
the craftiness,
is he going to set traps and is Frances and gone going to be fall for those
traps?
The other question is,
can all can Alster Overeem take a shot from in Ghana and Ghana has legitimate
absolute one punch knockout power,
extreme confidence and he's fresh and in his prime right now actually entering
his prime,
I mean arguably he hasn't even reached its prime yet because in Ghana was one of
those guys that had 31 years of age is near his physical prime,
but it's still learning.
He's still getting better at the sport and as he fights better and better
competition,
you're going to see more of a skill shine.
You're going to see where the holes are in his game and you're going to see how
he responds to adversity.
Hopefully we're going to get a chance to see all those things in his fight.
Um,
if Overeem wins,
there's a very good argument for him being next in line to fights.
Deep Abo chip.
The real question about the heavyweight division,
the real question other than,
um,
you know,
who's next for Steve Bay?
The real question is the health of Cain Velasquez.
Cain Velasquez,
in my opinion,
is without a doubt one of the greatest heavyweights of all time.
Um,
he's just a force of nature when he's in shape.
When you,
when you see the Cain Velasquez that beat Ben Rothwell,
when you see that Cain Velasquez that just stormed the division,
when you see him in the second and third fight with junior dos Santos,
that Cain Velasquez is a fucking monster.
The question is,
after all the surgeries,
back surgery,
knee surgery,
shoulder surgery,
can he come back and be that guy again?
Um,
as a fan,
I most certainly hope we can,
but we're really not going to know.
Um,
another fight in the car that's very interesting is Henry.
So Hutto and Sergio Pettis.
Sergio Pettis is the younger brother of showtime,
Pettis,
Anthony Pettis,
who was the former lightweight champion and Henry.
So Hutto of course is a former Olympic gold medalist,
the number two ranked fly weight in the world.
And Henry is coming off of an absolutely spectacular Kao of Wilson Hayes.
I was blown away by him in that fight and that fight,
he looked like some sort of a karate master.
I mean that was a,
it was a very,
very interesting fight.
Before that he lost a Benevidez and benefit is of course one of the most
experienced,
one of the best guys in the division and he lost it very,
very close fight.
A fight where I've talked to his coaches afterwards and they were really pissed
off by the decision they thought so Hutto could have gotten the nod,
but he rebounded and he rebounded versus Wilson Hayes and looked like a
completely different fighter.
The thing that excites me about this fight,
it's two things.
One,
the potential of Sergio Pettis.
Sergio Pettis is a young kid.
He's one of the youngest guys in the division.
He's the extremely talented younger brother of another extremely talented
fighter.
So he's had martial arts in his life.
You know,
most of the time growing up,
he's 24 years old now.
He trains under the Great Duke Roufus who in my opinion is one of the very best
guys in the division in terms of his ability to coach fighters.
He's fucking fantastic.
Doof not to division.
I mean,
I should say in,
in,
in the sport.
Uh,
Duke Roufus has just an amazing striking coach.
He's a former world Moy Thai champion himself,
outstanding kickboxer and extremely knowledgeable about both kickboxing and MMA
and one of the best guys in the world at training kickboxers for MMA.
I mean,
he's just fantastic.
And what we've seen from young Sergio,
we saw him get,
um,
submitted by Alex,
get Sarah's early on in his career and Alex is,
uh,
just slicker and caught him on the ground.
And uh,
and then we saw him lose again to Ryan Benoit.
I think that these losses,
especially for a young fighter,
are absolutely critical.
I think you find out what you're really made of you and you see what you need to
improve upon.
And in fighting tough guys early on,
like Alex Caceres,
like Ryan Benoit,
I mean,
and we're talking about two years ago he fought Benoit.
He was 21 years old then,
so or 22 years old,
he's 24 now.
So He's a really young kid,
still learning,
still growing on the job and uh,
has looked fantastic.
And his last few fights looked really good against John Moraga and looked even
better against Brandon Marino in his last fight,
which was a five round,
unanimous decision victory.
So this is my opinion,
is going to be the toughest fight of his career because Henry,
so Hutto just has that Olympic gold medal winner mindset,
the mindset of a galaxy Hutto I mean this guy is focused on being a champion 24
hours a day.
And if you look at the way he fought against Wilson Hayes,
I mean if,
if that's indicative of the kind of improvement that this guy can make and
carrying Gibbons who,
um,
is,
uh,
another fucking phenomenal Muay Thai coach,
he told me that this kid is just a sponge and just can learn so fast that a
ridiculous way.
And I think you looking at athletic prowess in Henry pseudo,
but I think maybe perhaps more important than that,
you're looking at his mind.
His mind is just ultra sharp and focused and determined and he's just got that
championship mindset.
I mean that's why he is an Olympic gold medalist and a wrestling.
So he's got unparalleled wrestling skill in the division.
And then on top of that,
if you look at the Wilson Hayes fight,
you look at radical improvements in his striking and movement.
I mean he looked like a combination of a Prime Leo Machida and Conor Mcgregor
versus with his movement against Wilson Hayes.
I think a lot of guys are realizing that karate style,
if you have all those other bases covered,
if you have great wrestling,
if you have submissions,
good takedown defense and good boxing skills as well as moy,
Tai,
everything else,
that karate stance,
that sideways stance that we see employed all the time by Wonderboy Thompson
that we see.
Um,
um,
we've seen a,
a bunch of different fighters.
Of course,
Leo Machida,
a bunch of different fighters use that stance inside the octagon.
Conor McGregor,
it's a very difficult stance to deal with.
It's a,
if you're good at it and if you're good at that movement,
that in and out side to side movement,
uh,
Michael Venom page has a very unusual take on that,
fighting and Bella tore.
He likes to fight like that too.
And of course he's a former point fighting champion.
That style is fucking hard to deal with.
It's really hard for guys to judge and if you're dealing with a guy like,
so Huda whose lightning fast on top of that and starts moving like that with
those worldclass wrestling skills with excellent striking,
um,
you know,
classic striking boxing and kickboxing,
very difficult to deal with.
I'm very interested to see what style he takes a,
or how he approaches this fight with Sergio Pettis.
He's quite a bit older than Sergio being 30.
Um,
that's a really interesting fight.
I'm very curious.
I,
I just do not know how that one's going to play out.
One fight that I don't know how to,
it's going to play out,
but I'm fucking beyond pumped for it is Eddie Alvarez and just engage you just
engage.
He is a fucking savage
and so's Eddie Alvarez.
Eddie Alvarez is a beast and I think a lot of people are looking past Alvarez.
Alvarez had just come off of that brutal knockout loss,
uh,
kind of a humiliating knockout loss to Conor McGregor.
And then after that he is involved in the,
the no contest,
uh,
versus um,
Dustin poor yet.
I believe that was an eye poke.
Um,
that is,
I'm trying to remember how that fight went down,
but I do not,
I feel like someone got poked in the eye.
Uh,
either way it's a no contest.
So that obviously doesn't move him up the ladder any and he's got to regroup.
Yeah,
no contest.
Here it is.
Yeah.
This was a,
okay,
now I remember what it was.
It wasn't an eye poke.
It was a knee to a downed opponent and it was a fucking phenomenal fight while
it played out against Dustin Poirier.
Yay.
They were going back and forth.
Now,
I remember the fight and poor ea had Alverez in some deep trouble and Alvarez
rebounded.
And Alvarez I believe,
hit Dustin employee Aa with a knee while he was down.
Yeah,
that's exactly what happened.
And interesting.
Yeah.
See,
this is what happened.
Pour.
Yay.
Um,
Alvarez,
you know,
Herb Dean was Safat defending it,
saying that Alvarez didn't intentionally need pour.
Yay.
And if I remember,
the fight is a crazy war.
Uh,
Alvarez had been rocked.
[inaudible] had been,
Brock poet was bloodied and um,
Alvarez hit him with an unintentional knee,
um,
that could have resulted in a disqualification when for poor.
Yay.
And Paula was saying that he looked at it as a win,
which is,
uh,
interesting.
Um,
so anyway,
pull a rebounded from that fight obviously,
and uh,
stopped Anthony Pettis in his last fight so that the division is just crazy in
me.
Unbelievably hot right now.
Um,
and everybody waiting to see what the fuck happens with Conor McGregor
rebounding.
But Eddie Alvarez with a no contest.
And before that,
the Kale lost econom McGregor desperately needs a win.
And he's coming in there against one of the most fucking savage guys in the
division.
Just engaging,
showed in that Michael Johnson fight what he's made of and a lot of people were
very excited to see him inside the octagon.
He had been fighting in the world series of fighting and looking like an
absolute monster,
but against what a lot of people thought was just not the same caliber of
competition as the UFC offered.
And so they wanted to see what would happen if he fought a real world class
fighter.
And what we saw in the Michael Johnson fight,
it's adjusting gauge.
He who fights,
uh,
I don't want to say reckless,
but he puts himself in danger and it's one of the things that makes him so
exciting.
He forces his will on people.
He's a ferocious striker and a,
an excellent wrestlers as well,
and just fucking puts it on fighters.
He tests there will,
he puts tremendous pressure on fighters.
And the,
the fight with Michael Johnson was just a pleasure to watch,
just so much fun and so fucking crazy.
There was so much chaos in that fight.
And a lot of people were introduced to just engage you from that fight.
The hardcore fans had known him already from the world series of fighting and
had heard about him through the Internet.
But the UFC fans and uh,
the people that were watching that night,
they really got a chance to be treated too.
Does the kind of chaotic fight that is really going to bring like a of the
casual fan when they see a guy like just engaging fight.
It's really gonna make you a fan of this kid.
Just his style is just,
there's very few guys,
I mean other than,
I mean Matt Brown who I talked about before,
but even Matt Brown is capable of winning so many different ways.
Whereas Gagey he's gonna probably try to knock you out or get,
I mean,
he's even said himself that he might get knocked out.
You're probably going to see me get knocked out.
He said,
uh,
over the next few years he's got that mindset,
this kill or be killed mindset.
And,
uh,
it's just absolutely fascinating to see this kid compete inside the octagon
because he's so fucking crazy because he's such a fucking animal inside the
octagon.
He just got this,
uh,
undeniable killer instinct and indomitable spirit.
And there's levels to this game.
There's levels physically,
and he's at a very high level physically,
but there's also levels mentally.
And that's what excites me about Justice Gagey is,
is the,
the mental level.
He just has zero quit in him and he's 100% ferocious.
So him fighting a fucking animal like Eddie Alvarez,
that's just a recipe for a good time.
And we're going to get to see that and we're going to get to see that next
Saturday night live on paper view.
Woo.
So how long have you been doing this here for nine minutes.
Black and fucking talk a lot.
Huh?
So,
uh,
also on the undercard,
here's another five.
That's a big fight.
Um,
this is,
uh,
Charles all Avera verses Paul Felder.
Paul Felder continues to impress.
I'll tell you what,
Paul Felder's a fucking phenomenal,
uh,
commentary guy too.
He did commentary guy,
color commentator.
He did a fantastic job doing commentary for Dana White's Tuesday night fight
show and as [inaudible] Tuesday night contenders show.
And uh,
he's done some a UFC events now as well.
And just excellent,
great enthusiasm,
very knowledgeable,
great talker,
smart,
articulate guy.
And he's fighting Charles all of Vera Saturday night.
Now,
Charles all Avera is a guy who has had mixed success inside the octagon and his
best.
He's been incredible and he shows a great range of very technical striking and
very,
very solid Brazilian Jujitsu,
but he's had some tough losses.
The,
the Kale lost a cub.
Swanson,
um,
is he burst onto the scene with a,
an amazing victory,
um,
way,
way back in the day.
See,
this is not even Efrain.
Escudero was his second fight inside of the octagon actually,
and he got him by standing rear naked choke.
That was a big fight because Efrain Escudero had won the ultimate fighter and it
was just,
it was a big victory for him.
And he went down,
he lost to cowboy Serone.
Um,
he got a coyote and the first round he,
uh,
lost to Jim Miller.
He got submitted.
And then the cub Swanson Kao,
he got beat up by Frankie Edgar in a very fun fight.
Three Round New Anna you unanimous decision.
Then a Max Holloway put it on him and stopped him in the first round.
Then Anthony Pettis submitted him.
So he's had some,
some ups and downs.
Ricardo Lamas,
Kod,
em,
uh,
excuse me.
Ricardo Lamas finished in by submission in the second round,
so he beat,
we'll Brooks by submission in the first round of his last fight and got back on
track.
Looked excellent in that fight and fought that fight.
You know,
it was like,
it was a real do or die fight for him against,
we'll Brooks a guy who was coming over from Bella tour,
a guy who was very talented and a Oliveira wound up submitting him.
There was a big victory for him and in my opinion,
this is one of the most dangerous fights for him right now at this stage of his
career.
Because Paul Felder is a fucking killer.
He's an animal.
He's very,
very strong physically.
He's a big 155 pound doors.
All.
Avera is a smaller 155 pounder.
I guy was fought at one 45 before,
but just really had a hard time making that weight.
Um,
fell.
Just going to have a power and strength advantage and all Avera is going to have
to be crafty and in my opinion,
his best way to win this fight is to get this fight to the ground.
And that's going to be a tall order,
a very tall order.
Um,
Felder's just a very aggressive,
very durable and extremely aggressive guy and 155 pounds.
Can I say aggressive one more time.
Um,
I really loved his fight against,
um,
well he's got,
had some amazing fights inside the octagon,
but what would I liked?
I liked his fights against,
I like his fight against Barboza because the Barboza fight showed him against
one of the very best strikers in the division and he'd got out struck.
He lost that fight,
but he was in it every second of the fight and he was trying to win up until the
very end.
Um,
he's had some ups and downs inside the octagon,
but he's won two in a row,
both by knock out both in the first round and,
um,
the Barboza fight and the Ross Pearson fight or to decision losses that he got a
split decision against Ross Pearson.
He beat Danny Castillo and a spectacular spinning back fist knock out,
um,
Jason's saga before that.
I mean,
and the Barboza fight I think was just a good example of like where this guy's
hard is that fought against one of the best and fastest strikers in the division
and was in it to the end.
It was a real learning experience for him and that was a also fight of the
night.
So I think Felder at this stage of his career is really coming into his own.
I don't think he's in his prime yet.
I think,
uh,
at 33 years of age,
we're starting to see the very best of him.
And he's,
he's got an incredibly bright future,
but also you gotta realize that 33 years of age,
she kind of got to get after it.
Right now.
I mean this is the time for him and,
uh,
for Olivera Oliver has got to capitalize on that victory that he just had over.
We'll Brooks and you know,
he's a little bit younger at 28 and still got massive potential and an
incredible amount of experience for a guy who's a 28 years old.
So this fucking card is just stacked.
This card is stack from top to bottom.
I mean,
you've got 'em cowboy Oliveira versus Yancey Madeiros is on that fight and David
Tamer is on that fight,
the fight card as well against drug car clothes.
Now that's a fucking sleeper.
That's the big sleep or fight their cause.
David Tamer is a fucking vicious Stryker,
I mean,
real world class striker and he's only 28 years old.
And David Tamer really let everybody know what the fuck is up when he fought
Landover Nada.
A lot of people had no idea who he was,
uh,
up until that fight,
even though he had one,
two fights in a row by Kao in the Octagon.
Um,
when you got to see that kid compete a against a really talented striker like
land Vanatta and just out strike him every step of the way,
you really got to see how good he is.
And again,
at 28 years of age,
I don't think we've seen the best of him yet.
I think he is a,
he has just got a massive,
massive amount of potential and that's the fight that I think is the big sleep
or fight on this car that a lot of people are just,
you know,
not quite aware of it.
And the guys fighting Dzhokhar close eight to know with one draw and very
fucking dangerous fighter as well.
You know,
he's coming from two victories in a row,
uh,
in the UFC and uh,
this will be his,
probably his most dangerous fight against Tamer.
Tamer is just a wild,
fast dynamic striker with legit worldclass kickboxing Muay Thai skills.
Very,
very fun card.
So that's going to be next Saturday night.
Also.
Teesha Torres is going to be fighting the karate.
Heidi,
karate hottie Michelle Waterson.
That should be a fun fight as well.
Teesha Torres,
who's a,
an outstanding striker and Michelle Waterson who,
uh,
employs a lot of that karate styles,
whether we're talking about that side where it's sideways stance,
she's got good kickboxing skills as well.
Good submission skills and uh,
Teesha Torres is going to most likely try to keep this fight on the feet.
There should be a lot of fun.
I mean,
um,
Michelle lost her last fight to rose,
Nama Eunice,
but,
uh,
she'd be Paige vanzant by submission before that in a a very,
very impressive fight.
Uh,
Angela McGauna,
she'd beat her by submission before that and Jessica Pinay,
she beat her in Invicta,
uh,
by decision before that.
Uh,
and you know,
she's a,
she's got a lot of hype behind her one because of she's got a unique style.
She's fighting out of Jackson's,
uh,
in Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
and she's also a very beautiful young lady.
And of course people like that.
That's a very interesting fight.
Um,
the whole car,
this is like a great card from top to bottom.
It should be a lot of fun.
But again,
the sleep or fight,
like I said,
is David Tamer.
And your car close.
Keep an eye on tamer.
That mother fucker is wild.
Uh,
all of air versus Felder should be a lot of fun.
Alvarez versus gauge,
do not go to the bathroom,
do not get popcorn while that fight is going on.
As long as it lasts,
I fight will be chaos.
Um,
I think so.
Hutto versus pedis is going to be a very interesting test to see where pedis is
at this stage of his career and to see if so Hutto can continue to show these
massive jumps and leaps of improvement that he showed in his last fight against
Wilson Hayes,
the Overeem and Gyno fight.
Fuck.
Amen.
That could be chaos.
I am interested to see whether or not Francis in Gando can catch Alistair
Overeem or whether or not he finds himself against a guy who's far too crafty
for him at this stage of his career.
I mean,
we really don't know.
Um,
he fought our Laskey in his last fight,
but with all due respect,
I do not believe that [inaudible] is in the same category as over him.
I think Overeem represents another level of danger.
And on top of that over is a very good ground game that a lot of people are
forgetting about Overeem one,
the Abu Dhabi European trials he submitted Vito Belfort.
I mean,
Overeem has legitimate submission skills submitted,
Mark Hunt over in,
can submit guys,
he's got good wrestling skills as well.
You've got to remember he took Stephan struve to the ground with a beautiful
take down that Teekay owed him when he got him to the ground.
Um,
he may choose to try to take Francis and Ghana to the ground.
We might,
we might see that.
We don't know.
Um,
it's just,
it's a very interesting fight to see where in Ghana is at this stage of his
career and the biggest test of his career so far and a fight that Overeem was
looking for.
Overeem believes that he has the skills to put in Ghana in his place and
reestablish himself as the number one contender in the heavyweight division.
That makes,
uh,
that makes me very happy to see that fight.
I'm very pumped.
And then of course for all the marbles in the featherweight division,
Max Holloway versus Josie motherfucking,
although for the title,
you know,
with a guy like all know,
you got to remember you're talking about a guy who was the best ever at
featherweight for a long fucking time.
You're talking about a god that up until that Conor McGregor fight had beaten
everybody that they put in front of him.
He rebounded fantastic from that fight with the Frankie Edgar fight and then got
beat down by Mac Holloway.
I want to see where he's at right now.
I want to see whether or not he can read browned and I want to see after 29
professional MMA fights at the highest level,
at 31 years of age,
does he still have what it takes to fight it a world championship level and can
he come back better than ever.
Now with Max Holloway,
he is.
He's a fucking killer.
Max Holloway has everything you want to see in a champion,
a championships mindset,
and the way he wanted to go down at 25 years of age too.
I mean,
just keeps getting better.
He's not even near his prime,
the way he wanted to go down to Brazil and beat Joe's I Aldo in Rio.
And the way he said it,
that he wanted to fight him in his country,
then that,
and that's what kings do.
They go to the other person's kingdom and take their throne.
And that's what he did.
Very exciting fight.
So I'm fucking pumped for next Saturday night.
Um,
now to answer some of the criticisms and questions,
a lot of people have been saying,
hey man,
you should probably do this with guests.
I am absolutely going to do this with guests.
The only reason why I didn't do this one with a guest is because of my pitch.
I'm on vacation and I felt like I owed everybody want,
cause this is how it was going to do one of these things every week.
But the next one I do,
I will bring in a guest and I'm going to bring in,
I'm going to try and bring in more fighters.
Um,
I think this is the best way I think to do a fight or podcasts,
not just,
I mean I'm definitely gonna do more like where I just sit down and do a regular
podcast with them for the jre podcast.
But when it comes to just a straight MMA podcast,
I'm going to do quite a few of these,
bring guys and bring some guys in that are interesting that don't think,
uh,
maybe uh,
um,
maybe some of you folks who've never heard talk before so that,
that'd be cool.
Um,
I'm also going to ask questions or a,
have you guys ask questions?
So what I'm going to do is,
um,
for the next one I'm going to put a post up on Instagram and allow you guys and
Gals and non-binary folks to put,
um,
how long do we have to say that for non binary,
how many of you are out there that are non-binary?
Is it really important to address you?
Do you feel left out?
If I don't humans,
I'm going to allow all of you humans to ask questions and we'll,
uh,
pick some good ones and throw those out there as well in the podcast.
So that's it for now.
Uh,
next week I got,
I got some good guests.
This week I've got some really fucking funny people.
I have CT Fletcher who's a,
I'm sure he's funny,
but he's also a power lifting legend.
He's going to be here.
Um,
Owen Smith,
the guy that I've been telling you folks about who's in my opinion,
one of the funniest motherfuckers on the planet earth and a guy who people are
sleeping on.
People just don't know how good Owen Smith is.
He'll be here.
Um,
Brian Keaulana will be here this week.
I got a lot of good guests this week,
so that's it for now,
friends.
And,
um,
thank you for tuning into episode two of the J r e m m a show.
And,
uh,
I'll talk to you guys soon.
Okay.
All right.
Bye.